have you ever been to Cleveland I have I
I went to school very very close to to
Cleveland and a good buddy of mine was
the biggest Cleveland guy I've ever
known Rory O'Malley we went to college
together with the sports guy like big
sports guy big just big for his city you
know I'm saying like just a big big rep
fist city and he we went to college
together and he we actually ended up we
did Hamilton together on Broadway he's
going to be the king here in LA still
freaked out like my thing is like
everybody comes up and yells Kelly
Clarkson to people if it's just you're
Hamilton so it's like do people always
come up to you and are just like talking
on stuff about Hamilton cuz it was such
a movement I feel like when I was a kid
and rent came out how popular that was
now blew up
that's why Hamilton is for this
generation it's just like enormous it
was that and it no it was weird you know
dahveed used to say this thing this I
love the double you used to say right
outside the stage door you were a Beatle
for a block you don't I mean like once
you cross the 8th Avenue it kind of died
down but it took its a time to get used
to getting recognized at the airport and
stuff like that I was I'd be looking
behind me like who were they looking at
yeah but it was you know a huge
phenomenon changed our lives yeah yeah
yeah but it also gave just really
talented people a chance an opportunity
to really showcase all that you were
capable of like how he wrote those songs
I mean my husband is a full-on cowboy
like raises cattle rode bulls like that
kind of guy
tears we went to New York and he was
like he was looking around going no but
looking at me right it was like he was
like crying like it was it was so good
just such a great moment in time but I'm
so glad that you have the music now that
you're doing yes I love the year
transitioning so you've done a biggest
show on Broadway literally but what was
your first theater role do you remember
my very first theater role was in
kindergarten I played Martin Luther King
and our black is wrong yes that's where
I start at the top
[Applause]
no I played monitor King in our black
history you know ceremony and I took it
very very seriously the teacher miss
Lewis you know she was she was really
kind to the kids it was like she wanted
you to memorize it but if you didn't it
was okay she would like sit next to you
and meld the words right before you had
to say them that's right but I knew all
my lines all five of my just one of the
many reasons I should never be an actor
but yes but I can't retain like how
y'all memorize all those lines because I
did musical theater growing up and I I
would almost like I mean sweaty pits my
stomach would hurt like this memorizing
that I've attained pretty well I still
might remember some of it I mean I think
it wasn't like you know Martin Luther
King had a dream something like that
[Laughter]
okay was it always theater for you
though or did you are you really into TV
as well oh I was a latchkey kid so we
want me to I watched you know far too
much TV
me too but look at us now yeah I used to
watch um like it's it's it was so bad or
good however you looked at it like I TV
sitcoms and stuff are still a huge
comfort to me like is it like when I go
to sleep and stuff I can laugh yeah I
can just put on like an episode of
cheers and like the theme song like puts
me I know all the theme song do you
really don't you remember like I mean I
feel like there's a time when every show
it was like the theme song was huge
yes making your way in the world today
yes I didn't know the word see I repeat
nothing
you know my favorite was what was the
one where they had the guy Arkel they
had what was what family management that
start and they're not that one lady that
went like oh like that was my favorite
one cuz she was just like wailing and I
was like I want to be her but mr. your
albums called mixer why did you call it
mr. a tiny little bit of mystery you
know I'm saying like it has a lot of
meaning to me but you know you can
understand this - it's like I'm super
interested in people listening to the
record and telling me why they think
it's called mr. it has tons of personal
meaning to me but I feel like the minute
I say why I called it that I'm not as
cool as you I'm always like oh I need to
be cooler
work on my mystery I have no I have no
filter I don't have you know so your
wife a daughter and your grandma we're
all on this record right this is I mean
look at what that's well is it you know
it's a deeply you know it's a personal
record it's a lot of the songs started
as journal entries you know and so I
wanted to you know so my family into the
not literally but so them into the
fabric of the thing rubs the lotion on
but so yeah we are my daughter there's a
little Easter egg or my daughter
introduces one of the tracks my wife
sings backup I begged her to sing back
but she's my favorite singer so my wife
sings backup all over this all over the
album you can hear her but yeah my
grandmother knew this this poem from the
time she was in the fourth grade it's a
poem called the psalm of life and I used
to I used to ask her to recite she knew
it from memory I know I would ask her to
recite it from my whole life you know
and the meaning sort of changed over
time like at first it was just like a
gag like I wonder if grandma still
remembers it and then as I got older
then you know I started to understand
the meaning of it and stuff so I had no
idea that it would be the last time but
that was on the record is a recording of
the last time my grandmother ever said
that yes to do that yeah it's so cool
that is the coolest thing and I think
you know we were talking about you
transitioning into like more the pop
world or whatever and it's like that's
the thing that fans love the
vulnerability I think and the fact that
you're welcoming them into your your
family your story and it's all right
there and they get to be a part of it
not just you singing but like walking
welcoming into the whole story and
opening on you I mean you went through
the same thing right I mean like when
people were first giving you songs to
sing and telling you what to sing and
then you you know found your voice as a
writer on your own I was lucky I fought
very hard for my first single so I got
to write on that one but it was but but
it was I did have to fight but I also in
the artists like I'm a writer and I love
writing what's in my heart head but I
also think like what a missed
opportunity for people that maybe don't
want to write and do pro records out or
seeing input records out but there's
these amazing nugget of songs that I've
been blessed to be able to record like
that's kind of cool too so I like doing
both yeah like like the greatest
compliment to me a friend of mine who
I've known a long time listen to the
record and the the message that he sent
to me was I feel like I got to know you
better
somebody that has known me for a very
long time yeah but it's a different
thing music opens up a different side of
you and it's just way more vulnerable
and it's cool and I wish you nothing but
success thank you so talented so cool so
funny I know I love that you knew the
lotion in the basket reference I will
not stop talking until you subscribe to
my youtube channel that's right and I
could talk a lot seriously not gonna
stop yep still here not going anywhere I
see you don't walk away from this